Rise and shine, Mr. Freeman. Rise and
[music]
shine.
In this problem, two radioactive
materials are being compared in an
environmental study. Material one starts
with twice as many atoms as material 2.
The half-life of material one is half as
long as that of material 2.
Both materials decay according to first
order radioactive decay and both are
observed over a 20-year period. After 10
years, which material will have a
greater reduction of its original amount
and what will that percentage remaining
be?
So in this problem, the first words that
we can pull out might be halflife.
Searching for this in the Environmental
Reference Manual version 1.6
will lead you to chapter 5 in a section
called half-life radioactive decay.
Since the materials are decaying at a
first order rate, we can pull the
equation from the reference manual as
follows where
n equ=
n sub0 * eus
0.693* 6 93
* t over tow
where
n sub0 is the original number of atoms,
n is the final number of atoms,
t is going to be the time, and toao is
going to be the halflife.
So, the question gives you the 20-year
period, but we don't care about that
because it's specifically asking over 10
years, what material will have a greater
reduction. So, t in this case is going
to be our time of 10 years.
Now, if we want to solve this problem
out, we can make some assumptions to do
so.
If you understand half- livives, you
probably already know the answer to this
question. But if you want to solve the
problem out all the way uh with numbers,
there are some assumptions that we can
make. So let's take material one
and
material 2.
And let's say that the original number
of atoms
N sub0 for material one is 200.
And to satisfy the constraint over here
that uh material one starts with twice
as many as material two, material two
will have 100.
Next, the halflife.
Same thing. The halflife of material one
will be half as long as that of two. So
let's just make this
one year and this two years.
And now all we have to do is solve this
equation above for each one.
So for material one, we're going to say
that n equals our n sub0 is going to be
* eus
0.69. 6 93
times
t again is 10 years
and our halflife is going to be 1 year
and this is going to give us a final n
of about 0.19.
Now if we divide 0.19
over the initial concentration
of 200
we will get
0.97
or 0.097%.
For material two,
let's say that n equ= an n sub0 of
* e to the minus 0.693.
Again t will be 10 and our halflife will
be
2 years.
And this will solve out to about 3.12
atoms.
So
dividing 3.12
by 100 just skip the middle part and
show that this gives us 3.12%.
So clearly material one will have a
greater reduction in its original amount
and it will be
just about 0.1%.
Don't confuse that when you round up and
accidentally select 0.01 instead.
So this problem is really easy to solve.
This question is mostly just being
presented to you to get you familiar
with where radioactive decay and
half-lifees are in the reference manual
as well as giving people who are maybe
experienced with this an instant
recognization that material one is going
to be the faster of the two to decay
just because of its smaller halflife.
And that's all it takes to solve this
problem. Wake up, Mr. Freeman.
Wake up. Smell the ashes.